why are you stepping down well it's been
a tough decision to make I've really
weighed up everything I've thoroughly
enjoyed having the responsibility of
being the Member of Parliament for
Roscommon looking after my constituents
and of course being the Westminster
leader up until last December but you
know I've taken the decision in the next
election is the time to to move on
um it's about how I can help contribute
to the case of Scottish independence
I've been appointed as the first
ministers business Ambassador I'll be
publishing a green industrial strategy
for Scotland over the course of the next
few weeks and I want to make sure that I
can use my influence that we move the
economy that we get the green economy
going that we get jobs and investment in
Scotland Selby continue to be active but
I'll be doing it in a different way and
oh yes of course I'll have some regrets
I guess from stepping away from
Westminster but it's the right thing to
do to move on to the next chapter is it
because your party is crumbling no
because I was committed as I've ever
been to make sure that we they finish
the job and I want to be part of that I
want to make sure that I'm supporting
himself I think I'm just going to
surprise people people as to what you
can do as first Minister he's got a good
team around him good team of ministers
advisors and I'm very much looking
forward to the the challenges that we're
going to be facing you're never going to
see Independence in your lifetime though
I want to make sure that we do that you
know I joined the SNP in 1978 it's been
a long time and I've got this burning
desire to make sure that we can train
Scotland for the better I want to grow
the economy I want to see this Green
Revolution the jobs that we can get to
make sure that we utilize the strength
we've got in our academic sector we get
the the startups the spin outs that come
from that and we give people hope that
we can do better yeah but are you going
to see Independence in your lifetime yes
I I actually firmly believe that that we
will do but we need to we need to show
as ever at the moment well yeah but
Keith what we need to do is to show to
the people of Scotland that we're worthy
of their trust and then we've got a
vision of a Scotland that would be back
in the European Union that one that puts
people at the heart of that you know
we've got the opportunity to increase
our green energy output about fivefold
over the course of the next few decades
let's make sure we get the jobs out of
that and let's make sure that can show
people that there's a better way there's
a better future I know that we're
capable of doing that now you've
certainly made your presence Felts in
the House of Commons I don't know if
we've got the grab of you when you were
in all sorts of trouble with Boris
Johnson quick look
under the power given to me by stunning
order number 43 I ordered the honorable
member to withdraw immediately from the
house
it's all right we don't need to bother
you called him a liar you called Boris a
liar well indeed I think many people
were congratulating me for standing up
and saying the things that they all knew
to be true we we should never have had
Boris Johnson as as prime minister I
regretted that we did I think he did a a
lot of damage and I had that
responsibility to use that voice as SNP
leader to stand up for people and you
know we've got the covert inquiry coming
down the line the people that have made
so many sacrifices I'm glad that even
though I'm standing down that we've seen
off Boris Johnson as as prime minister
over the course of that period you're
leaving the door open for labor to take
your seat at the next election no like I
you know at the end of the day it's
always up to the voters what they want
to do but I mean I increased my majority
in 2017 I did it again in 2019 the only
SNP MP to do that I trust that the
voters in my constituency will come back
and support whoever is the SNP candidate
in the next election look we've got a
job to do to show that we can be trusted
the election is going to be about change
it's about making sure that we've got a
response to the cost of living crisis I
know that the smt will be ready for that
challenge next year another challenge
they've got before that is Margaret
Ferrier she's been suspended for 30 days
for breaching covered uh lockdown rules
and that's
inevitably going to be a by-election
before too long and labor are definitely
chomping at the bit there well let's
wait and see we'll we'll choose a
candidate and we'll be ready for that
fight I'm glad that this episode you
acknowledge that maybe could win that
suit I think what we've got to do is
make sure that we set out our case but
why we need to return a hard-working SNP
for that constituency I'm glad that we
seem to be facing a by-election that's
right that that is the case I'm sorry
that Margaret's got herself in the
position that she is in but we need to
move on she should have gone as an MP
sometime before now but let's focus on
getting that violation and electing an
MP that can represent her constituency
acknowledge it could go to labor now
we'll make sure that we fight in this
election to make sure that it's an snpmp
return to represent the people of that
constituency and will you remember your
time as a politician well you know I can
look back to I think most importantly
what I've done for constituents and um
you know maybe surprisingly for a
Highland constituency issues of
migration A Journey For You hasn't it I
mean but physically
um and literally
um and figuratively not least because
how long does it take you to get home
well you know yesterday I left home at
10 30 and sorry not yesterday and Monday
left home at 10 30. got to Westminster
at half past seven at night it's a long
commute and you know I've got to do that
twice a week but I knew what I was
signing up for us I've no regrets about
that but you know okay I think one of
the things I had two families in the
constituency that faced deportation we
managed to stop that and you'll remember
the success that we had in getting the
orphans from Ukraine into Scotland last
year so these are probably high points
as well you can make a difference for
people these are the I think the things
that code and what were the questions
um actually funnily off when I talk
about one of these immigration cases a
family that were living in Scotland that
we thought were going to face
deportation quite early on and and I
think it's difficult not to get involved
in that not to get engaged in that there
are other cases a lovely women in the
constituency that we managed to help her
get a transfer down to hospital in
London for a lung transplant and gave
her some additional years I think when
you look at these things these are the
points that you remember when you've
used your office to to help people to
make a difference for them